AND THIS IS THE LIBERAL
ESTABLISHMENT.
THIS IS WHAT I'M FIGHTING.
>> Dan: AN UPDATE TO A STORY
THAT WE COVERED LAST NIGHT,
PORTLAND POLICE RELEASED PHOTOS
OF SUSPECTS IN VIOLENT ANTIFA
CLASHES THAT INJURED
CONSERVATIVE WRITERS AND OTHERS.
ACCORDING TO NEWS BUSTERS CBS,
MSNBC, AND "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
ALL IGNORED THE ANTIFA VIOLENCE
AND BEATING OF ANDY NGO.
JOINING US NOW IS HOST A REALITY
CHECK WITH DAVID WEBB ON
FOX NATION FOX NATION AND
COLUMNISTS AT THE HILL DAVID
WEBB.
AN INTRO TO THE MUELLER REPORT,
ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
BUT I WILL GO TO YOUR FIRST,
DAVID.
THE IRONY OF CONSERVATISM IS
CONSERVATIVE GOVERNMENTS
BENEFITING CONSERVATIVES AND
LIBERALS, BUT TO THE OPPOSITE IS
TRUE FOR A LIBERAL CITIES.
LOOK AT THE RUDY GIULIANI YEARS
COMPARED TO WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
NEW YORK WITH BILL de BLASIO.
THE CITY IS FALLING APART.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPEN IN
NEW YORK, WHAT HAPPEN WAS PROPER
POLICING AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THAT IS NOT A LEFT OR RIGHT
ISSUE.
A LAW ENFORCEMENT IS FRUSTRATED.
I TALKED TO OFFICERS IN CHICAGO
NOT JUST ABOUT THE JUSSIE
SMOLLETT CASE, BUT ABOUT HOW
THEY ARE POLICING.
AND THEY FEEL AT THE MAY ORAL
AGENCY THAT RUNS THE CITY DOES
NOT HAVE THEIR BACK.
IT IS NOT JUST THE MAYOR, BUT
THE ESTABLISHMENT.
I KNOW YOU ARE SEEING THE POLICE
IN SOME FORM OF REVOLT SAYING
THAT WE WANT TO DO OUR JOB TO
PROTECT CITIZENS NO MATTER WHAT.
THAT IS COMMON IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT, NOT THE
OUTLIERS THAT YOU SEE.
AND THE SUMMER WHEN IT HEATS UP,
YOU SEE THIS.
THE HOT DAYS OF SUMMER LEADING
TO A VARIETY OF THINGS THAT
INCREASE IN SHOOTINGS, BUT
ROBBERIES ARE ALSO UP.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE REPORTS IN
THE CITY IS, THEY ARE STARTING
TO SEE THAT IT IS AN INDICATOR
WHERE YOU ARE SEEING ROBBERIES
GOING TO THE PRECINCT LEVEL,
THAT COMPLETES FOR THE
COMMANDERS, THIS IS A REAL
PROBLEM NOT ONLY IN CHICAGO BUT
IN MANY CITIES AROUND THE
COUNTRY, LIBERAL RUN CITIES.
>> Dan: WHEREVER YOU SEE A
LIBERAL MONOPOLY WHERE THEY ARE
IN CHARGE OF THESE BIG CITIES,
SADLY MANY TIMES YOU SEE HIGH
CRIME, YOU SEE LAWLESSNESS, YOU
SEE SOME POCKETS OF POVERTY THAT
SEEM UNBREAKABLE, WHAT IS A
COMMON THREAD HERE, OBVIOUSLY IT
SEEMS TO BE THIS LIBERAL FORM OF
GOVERNMENT.
AM I READING THIS WRONG?
>> I THINK THAT YOU ARE READING
IT WRONG, WHEN HITCHCOCK WAS
MAYOR OF NEW YORK, IT WAS A
WONDERFUL CITY.
I LIVE IN NEW YORK, I THINK IT
IS A WONDERFUL CITY, I DON'T
SUPPORT BILL de BLASIO FOR
MANY OF HIS ECONOMIC REASONS,
BUT I
THINK HE WAY OVERSTATED THE
PROBLEMS IN NEW YORK AND
CONTRIBUTE THEM TO ONE PARTY
MORE THAN ANOTHER.
CHICAGO IS A DIFFERENT STORY.
CHICAGO REALLY HAS VERY, VERY
SERIOUS PROBLEMS.
SOME OF THE WEST COAST CITIES
HAS SERIOUS PROBLEMS.
BUT THEY ARE ENDEMIC TO URBAN
CENTERS.
WHERE I THINK WE REALLY DO HAVE
A PROBLEM THAT YOUR INITIAL
POINT MADE WAS ABOUT AND DEFIED
CITIES.
WHEN I HAVE SPOKEN AT SCHOOLS
LIKE BERKELEY, I'VE BEEN
THREATENED BY ANTIFA, AND I
THINK THAT THE GOVERNMENT HAS TO
DO SOMETHING TO STOP LEFT-WING
VIOLENCE TO LIBERAL MODERATE
SPEAKERS LIKE ME, I AM NOT
RADICAL ENOUGH FOR HIM ANTIFA.
THAT HAS BEEN A PROBLEM ON
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES, WE LIVE IN
A FEDERAL SYSTEM, AND THAT GIVES
AUTHORITY TO THE CITIES TO MAKE
THEIR OWN MISTAKES AND THEIR OWN
DECISIONS.
THE PRESIDENT REALLY CANNOT
INTRUDE ON THAT EXCEPT IN
EXTREME CASES.
WE HAVE TO LEAVE IT TO THE
CITIES AND TO THE VOTERS TO
DECIDE WHETHER THEY LIKE WHAT
THEY GET IN THE CITIES OR NOT.
>> ON THE LEGAL ANALYSIS, I WILL
DEFER TO ALAN, LOOKING GREAT FOR
THE SUMMER OUT THERE.
ABOUT THE ADMINISTRATION HAD
DONE SOMETHING.
AND I HAVE HAD THIS DISCUSSION.
I LIVE IN NEW YORK AND I LOVE IT
LIKE HE DOES, THAT KOCH HAD A
RELATIONSHIP AND AN
UNDERSTANDING OF PROPERTY PROPER
POLICING, THAT IS A KEY
DIFFERENCE.
UNFORTUNATELY IN THE CITIES THAT
FRACTURED RELATIONSHIP.
ON THE ANTIFA ISSUE, THE FBI HAS
WEIGHED IN, HE IS RIGHT ABOUT
THE SUPREMACY CLAUSE ON A NUMBER
OF ISSUES.
I WOULD NEVER ARGUE WITH, HIS